that uh if queens came off very early it
was just a really defensive end game for
weighie and he ended up blundering
losing and uh likewise in the last game
he took a lot of risks and was suffering
throughout so he needs something
different simply weighty and
hopefully he'll be exciting hopefully
it'll be some kind of attacking chess
where at least he can ask levon some
difficult questions
bring it on
i think i've played that rubbish before
i mean i i
this this this is
more like it i love it i love it
um
a wild move there but um i mean mama
jaroff is a player he's played this kind
of jab
on occasions but um yeah i mean
david over i'm just very happy to see
that yeah i mean i'm not sure what to
say we first we've got to say it's
definitely not a mouse slip it looks
like white has just blunted a pawn but
he's giving it up he's sacrificing a
pawn in order to make the black knight
lose a bit of time if black knight if
the black knight goes and captures that
white pawn the white g-pawn then white
will expand even further in the center
in at least over the next few moves and
yeah i mean i've struggled to understand
why the sacrifice is uh viable to be
honest but i don't think it really is
it's the answer but it it it it's sort
of a this move you can play one move
before uh it's called the kilkenny
gambit
uh which i've i've had some fun with
myself and i i mean this is a solid
choice isn't it you know because you
have to ask yourself is it really good
for white to have that pawn there in the
first place as well um
but
brave stuff from where ye in in in a do
or die situation it's certainly brave
and uh what i like about this particular
opening choice is that uh where you
faced it himself against mama jaroff
just uh recently in the chesapore
masters okay
and that game was a draw actually
and uh well
there's been obviously a deviation from
that particular game but uh now the
players are actually freestyling and
when the players are on their own then
we are going to see creativity happen
okay so levon iranian grabs a pawn but
not the pawn we were expecting maybe and
the acid test of this whole opening had
to be to grab white's g-pawn this pawn
that's marching down the board now
attacking destabilizing black's knight
i'm assuming that a knight is going to
jump into the center of the board
but i think where he's opening has been
justified we've already got a really
irrational position where anything can
happen he's already on the front foot
this time yeah definitely he's going to
take over center
with two pawns um if black ever castles
king side he has to worry about that
lone straggler coming towards his king
um he's only one pawn down at the moment
and that's nothing to worry about so
you know in a do or die situation this
is this is a perfect choice and i i
think the opening's gone well here he
comes he's throwing them all up the
board harry and gary going on an
adventure
and uh yeah i mean this just looks
fantastic yes you're pawn down but this
black pawn it's doubled long term it's
weak anyway so you don't need to rush to
recapture it i like this one simon i
mean the alternative right was going
for space in the center going for a
space grab but
i guess at some point these pawns might
be a bit weak there's no reason to play
in the center when he's committed to one
flank already and
it's consistent
he's hoping i guess that levon aronian
castles into the
firing line and the white pawns will
step forward at some point explode open
the position instead levon doesn't
commit the black king it stays in the
center for now and he just moves his
bishop he wants to line up on this
diagonal yeah
but in fairness though levon hasn't done
anything wrong
you know he he
didn't take the bait i would argue that
in this position this is doing something
wrong ivanka not taking this pawn it's a
free pawn
yeah
that's true i i take your point no one
takes that pawn it's weird when whenever
you play this move everyone's too scared
to take it i guess
as far as i know the uh
well the computer
kind of uh
suggestion is to push this pawn forward
now it becomes like a dutch opening
where black is just a pawn up but it's
very sharp
i mean you can push this pawn and it
gets a bit complicated but
um yeah back to the current position
and uh ivanka you were saying maybe
hasn't done anything too drastic at
least black
so
how does levon develop here
okay do we think level and ronin he's
too scared to castle this way because
the white pawns is he going to try
castle the other one on the other flank
on the queen side but maybe white's
going to get there first david i mean if
i was white here i'm thinking i'm not
castling kingside um i i need to break
it up yeah let's get on with it castle
queen side push the pawn in the middle
up
open up the board get to his king check
mate bring it off to the next game win
that playoffs happy days champion
easy
easy easy
wow this looks like a cool game and
david i saw that you entered the selfie
competition i did yeah very cool but you
forgot landscape
sorry guys
i've only been listening to landscape
for the last few months
very cool selfie
and you too tweet yourself using the
hashtag chess champs
this night was hit uh the black knight
moved
and
okay how does he continue the attack
i love the fact that wei yi has been
playing quickly as well yeah they've
been freeless i think ivanka used used
that word freestyling they've been
freestyling for a while already but bang
bang bang the moves are continuing yeah
that's what he needs exactly what he
needs i mean we've seen him pause we've
seen him being indecisive and that has
come back to bite him and
whilst
levon is sorry when you is thinking well
you mentioned the selfie challenge oh
hang on a second there is a move and a
nice aggressive one at that the queen
steps forward two squares and starts
eyeing up the pawn sitting there on g7
yeah looks looks good it's the center
white saying to black hey why don't you
castle but also into my attack you're
ready just to win your pawn back as well
here yeah i mean like like you say the
one on the king side but you can develop
your last piece and take a pawn i really
like white's position i mean i'm always
a bit of an optimist in these things and
i i think fortune should favor the brave
uh really you know your brave play i
mean you were talking about cassia
and uh you know the goddess of chess i
mean it surely should be
smiling on wei yi for this play
in this game yeah
i mean levon aronian i'm surprised he's
been playing so quickly after being hit
with this massive surprise on move three
which surely he hasn't analyzed in any
serious detail but uh
yeah he wasn't brave wei yi was very
brave choosing this opening levon wasn't
brave enough to grab that all-important
pawn
so
it would be right according to the chess
goddess that black is on the back foot
suffering slightly i mean where'd you
put your king as black this is this is
the key thing do you go do you go king
side which i don't you know there's no
immediate danger i say very softly
or did you go queen side where
there's no immediate date i don't know
they both look scary don't they to be
honest but it's also scary leaving it in
the middle and you've got to make this
decision
at some point
pretty much now because of this one
being under fire and like you said simon
i mean if you go this way
um if you go to the queen side with the
black king it doesn't feel safe at all
to be honest for example white can just
regain a pawn
i don't think we'll see a capture of
this bishop but if we do then suddenly
some threats along this line yeah the
white pawn stepping forward maybe a big
threat
if you go the other way then
at least you have to kind of find your
nerves find your courage write a portal
step forward and actually both of these
pawn pushers are on the cards
it's yeah it's really scary time to be
the black king
it's not what you want when you're in uh
yeah if you just want to draw right you
just want a nice simple position
you have uh
just a easy play and instead you're just
thrown into this deep dark forest where
nothing is making sense
great opening choice actually in you
know
it's got uh lev out of his book and it
scared him because he didn't take the
pawn as david said and
you know if you don't accept these
gambits generally the the side gets
quite good position okay he's played a
move david yeah he's pushed the f pawn
so i guess the idea is to firstly keep
the tension keep his options open he's
still saying okay maybe i'll go this way
maybe i'll go the other way uh you keep
guessing if you attack on one side i'll
run the other way so
i kind of like this also he's kind of
setting up a nasty pawn push so for
example your move now simon taking this
pawn
which otherwise would win back the pawn
and look fantastic i guess this would
run into
a hit on the white queen and white's
queen can no longer defend the bishop
next to her so the white queen for
example could step back but
the white bishop will disappear so a
small trap included in the position it
does feel a bit loose however
um if we take the pawn a question for
black does he take with the queen try
and hurry to get the queens off if you
take with the pawn it does look very
loose this kind of structure black will
never castle this way at least now
so we know that but
yeah i quite like it from level neronian
this last move pushing the pawn keeping
his options open
it looks like both players playing great
actually right now yeah great yeah
and wei he's more sensible with his
clock in this game much more sensible
yeah
but it's a bit late he maybe should have
stumbled on the strategy of playing
quickly um
before today's action started yeah
game three when he's already in a
must-win situation it's not easy anymore
to kind of suddenly adapt and switch
oh but imagine if he wins this game a
game four
bunch of confidence were
awayyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyyy
y yo definity could happen yeah exactly
and it would be the start of perhaps a
comeback i mean we have seen people turn
it around absolutely i do remember i
think it was magnus carlsen he won two
games against wesley so i want to say it
on demand
yeah yeah it's possible i mean uh if
you're playing like this you're playing
with
this aggression then you know it can uh
again you know you can really throw your
opponent off guard it kind of shows you
i mean i i don't know how often this
move will move three is actually being
played um but not often and it just
shows you how rich chess is because uh
you know they're banging out a lot of
theory in a lot of the other lines but
this is an incredibly rare move on move
three in a very very common position
it's a it's a kind of a modern idea uh
given up the pawn and and it gives hope
to me as a chess player it's like chess
is not dead it also gives hope because
the computer hates this move but the top
players in the world are playing this
which i also like because it's basically
saying the computers are not always
right or if they are right there's still
a lot of it's different when humans are
playing chess so there's a lot of
positive things about such a move uh and
being creative
is is something you should all try at
home because it's fair enough following
your chess ball courses and just trying
to remember stuff but going your own way
and creating things like this is is one
of the most fun things to do in chess
you know you should enjoy playing at the
end of the day enjoy your moves enjoy
playing even if you lose you can still
try to enjoy the process even though
that's not easy
do you reckon he played the fleetwood
mac song go your own way before this oh
you're wrong
uh played this pawn move
what other lyrics is appropriate for
this one it must be quite a lot you know
um my brain is a bit blurry tell
everybody i'm on my way
this position is livening up even more
if we go back to the game position wow
maximum tension we were talking about uh
kind of this pawn push being a threat
for black
he just said okay i'll push forward
instead look at all these pawns i mean
it's just chaos you can capture any of
them as black but levonot said nope i'm
not gonna dare to capture any of these
white pawns too dangerous i'm gonna
castle the black king to safety i say
safety it might not be safe on the side
for much longer white also has the
option of stepping forward with his pawn
i mean look how much chaos there is here
that's brilliant i love it
i love a good bit of chaos yeah um it's
always fun and he's played it yeah and
he's gone straight in those white pawns
look so dangerous they do they certainly
do and uh the question now that
lev has to face is do you capture that
pawn or do you just
walk away with the queen because
it's difficult
yeah if you walk away
i guess you have to decide what to do
here the rook will be attacked and if
you take this pawn there's a nasty check
and the night might drop so i think he
had to capture as he has just done um he
has just taken this pawn
uh in this position but
okay where he is now thinking he can
capture this way he can first also
capture this pawn i mean which way do
you go this one this one
yeah i mean that pawn in the center
attacking the queen just looks so
tempting i mean like you know you got
that pawn there what a fawn
it's just prodding your opponent and
gaining a tempo i i you know that move
is kind of an automatic move to me uh to
i mean there could be better options but
that pawn is is really juicy
really nice the queen moves the question
is what next lavon just shook his head
what could white try does he take this
pawn maybe you can even think about a
check couldn't you throw in the check
first yeah i'd like to check and make
give a square to the knight and the
bishop coming in to the yeah fianchetto
position in some cases is one attempting
idea isn't it yeah i was definitely
tempted i was always
the
move that david's highlighting
um yeah this bishop like you said simon
long diagonal you can imagine a
situation where if black is too slow
then suddenly everything lines up yeah
very scary this for lev
i mean this you know where you could not
have asked for a better opening here to
to fight
which is great
and uh yeah i don't know do you guys
find it's all about winning i had quite
a tough game about gammon yesterday
[Laughter]
maybe some dice were thrown yeah
by one of us
i've never seen in my whole chest career
anyone as competitive as
but i did win after sort of throwing
simon's dices away at some point i
didn't accept whatever you know
another great game back ever no it's a
really fun game it's nice to have a
little change of chess you know any game
that makes you think is is obviously
good absolutely it's a fun game but it
is obviously a dice game so there is a
lot more luck in it than it is in chess
is there any luck at all in chess yes i
would argue that and
it's actually to do
with your opponent i would say because
sometimes you play perfect chess and
your opponent also plays perfect chess
that's luck sometimes your opponent
that's bad luck actually uh if you play
perfect chess and your opponent plays
badly it just crumbles that's good luck
and uh something you kind of make you
make your opponent play bad chess not
necessarily sometimes your opponent just
falls on their own sword you know
something is off with their mental state
that day and they just make mistakes and
they just collapse very quickly and they
grant you a free game
it happens and i just kind of consider
that luck and
sometimes you make a blunder and your
opponent doesn't see it
again
it exists and uh you consider yourself
fortunate when those things happen yeah
i think in online chess there's even
more kind of luck there's even more
variability than in over the broadcast
for example this tournament alone we've
seen mouth slips we've seen
disconnections i mean imagine mama jarov
got a free
free three points in the prelims just
because zhu and june disconnected in a
very balanced position
so occasionally things happen like that
we've seen various mouse slips we've
seen
kind of accidental pre-moves we've seen
a whole bunch of things over the board
chests there's
it's mostly on the board kind of luck
where as you vancouver mentions you kind
of rely on certain factors that are out
of your control you rely on your
opponents maybe fallibility and
yeah it's
online chess at least i blame luck when
i loose or when i'm asleep
i don't know whether it's the
chess gods or whatever i'll tell you
what it was just pure luck no skill
yesterday
nothing to do with skill there clearly
all luck there 100
and okay this is the game is following
the lines that we predicted and
whilst uh levon is considering how to
defend
and where he is considering how to
attack well we are running a selfie
competition
and abhishek tells us that they are
cycling in the vast wilderness of lake
district is so much fun wow similar to
enjoying the melt water champions just
tour broadcast on youtube thank you very
much for your nice words abhishek and
tanushri
is saying rory lopez and the finale
let's call this the perfect sunday night
see you again in the next tournament
definitely yeah and
again abhishek he seems to be
multitasking maybe through the
multiverse because he's in lake district
now front seat on the upper deck is my
favorite place to sit on the bus in
london oh either i'm just standing
outside or playing chess with random
strangers on the chess 24 app and i have
to say i agree with him it's really good
to sit on the upper deck oh yeah and if
you can get the front the front seats
that's the best perfect view although
i'll confess i used to love this as a
kid i used to run for that spot now as
an adult i stay away because you know
you know that if there's an accident
you're going to fly wow
that's true safety first yeah
all right well wei yi
he has been more sensible with his time
in this game but now thinking for two
minutes yeah i think we can't blame him
too much in the current position because
because it is so wild it is maybe a
critical situation as well he needs
something now wei ideally he's still one
pawn down as white
and i do like what irony has done with
his knights it's a bit kind of
reminiscent of the last game when
aronian put the two white knights in
front of his king he's done the same now
the two black knights are great
defenders
still a lot of potential in white's
position i've got to say i look i can
see a whole bunch of ideas you mentioned
some uh simon ivanka but it's just
putting those ideas together i think
i guess the obvious ones are the night
jumps here the first you know you
probably look at the most aggressive
moves first i mean if we talked about
the process of elimination if you're
trying to find a move in a position
my reasoning is uh you you just
calculate the first move that comes your
mind but that should be the most
critical move because uh you should
always try to play in a forcing way i
feel if it works then you can move down
the list and well here i guess
both night jumps are quite quite
tempting and i'm quite surprised
actually i mean uh to me to my eyes this
position looks fantastic for white just
shows what a complete optimist i am uh
when in actual fact that the computer is
sort of saying it's it's fine for black
and we have another move uh a move i did
not expect here
yeah very surprising pushing
the a pawn forward
the idea is straightforward the idea is
simple you want to kick away this black
knight but for a few reasons maybe
surprising um also simon you mentioned
just these night jumps uh this one looks
so logical bringing a knight and queen
into the attack the other one bringing
the knight to put pressure on this black
knight
and uh yeah this pawn push
firstly how big a threat is this pawn
push secondly does black have a ways to
counter-attack i mean one idea for black
would be to shuffle the king
yep this is maybe the most logical move
he's just played shuffle the king
towards the corner and if white's pawn
steps up at least the black knight has
options you could step back uh he's
cleared the square now for the black
knight you could make an argument oh
whoops me and my arrows you could make
an argument for stepping into the center
as well
i think does that this is a much more
proactive move i mean this is where you
got the temptation because you only need
a draw to go passive big mistake go
active because the white king is weak as
well
yeah
the white king is weak as well and if we
take this knight off the board we see
another capture the problem for white is
you don't really want to swap the queens
off remember you need to win and also in
a position like this there is a risk
that this pawn actually becomes more of
a weakness than a strength it could be a
real target in the endgame so you don't
want to trade the queens and if you take
with a rook instead again some potential
issues and firstly
i could see a situation where black's
rook is quite active on the e-file maybe
black's rook swings this way indirectly
threatens the white queen in some lines
yeah simon you actually you called it i
mean this king is potentially
the more vulnerable of the two right now
yeah this often happens doesn't it when
you're you're playing this wild way uh
if
if the first wave is repelled then it's
your you know it can actually you know
the counter attack comes uh just also
like say a quick load to jerry graham
who who just did a tweet there who runs
the bom ratty tournament island and uh
one of my favorite tournaments so hello
to jerry um
how cool yeah you play a lot of
tournament segment
um i don't play that many i play there's
this tournament in ireland i've played
for last 20 years and it's just a
weekend tournament um but it's uh it's
in a really nice part of ireland where
there's a castle and lots of nice pups
so it's uh it's a really really really
nice tournament one of my favorites and
yeah peter svidler's playing there
wesley so uh
loads these people come over because
it's uh it's just a beautiful tournament
to play yeah it's a very fun tournament
as well and there's a reason i think
it's unre it's unrated
thank goodness
because yeah you're encouraged also to
have a good time that's the whole
emphasis it's have a good time play
chess and if you are t total this is
kind of a little bit frowny
it doesn't matter but you know it yeah
yeah sort of um if you a lot of people
do drink guinness during the game shall
we say yeah
well a bunch of moves the bar is liking
this for lavon david that's really
turning in black's favor and i think
it's just that one factor that simon's
been discussing the white king
is very weak now actually
we praised wai's play and i think he's
played great but he did seem to lose a
lot of momentum pushing that white a
pawn up the board it seemed to help
black do what he wanted in the first
place and it cost white two valuable
tempe
right now
the black knight could leap out the way
to various squares and there would be an
attack on the white queen from black's
rook on c8
i mean white king just looks so airy uh
the black queen i could definitely see
activating at some point for example
black's f pawn could actually capture
there's an open line for the black queen
to use
just so many holes suddenly if you
compare it to the black king black's
king safe as houses yeah one night in
front of it yeah totally turned and uh
and i'm also wondering okay he moves his
queen i also wonder whether there was
any direct
moves with the knight
and this reasonable move
although i do feel the queen perhaps is
a little bit out of the action the hair
yeah she's not great on this square
shape
you're going to play that in the white
night why didn't you take the pause
wait
can you really put your rook there
really because the night
really nice trick from uh
wei yi i think
although
yeah it's really really complicated here
we have to jump in ivanka you think
there's a winning move for black maybe
well this is a tempting move that's my
instinct it said well the first move i'm
going to look at is the knight will move
out of the way and attack the queen but
this is a trap his intention is to play
knight takes night giving up the white
queen
letting it fall because now after a
night capture there's a check and a fork
at the end and if we do a quick count
white has won a rook and two pieces just
for the black queen which is also on
side uh offside sorry so uh white would
be doing great here also the deep one
so
in the current game position he didn't
go for this night jump instead pushed
his pawn
this is nice actually you know i
didn't fall for the trap hook line and
sinker like i did and instead uh
liberates the light squared bishop
threatens a very deadly attack by
pushing the pawn forward and
now threatens this night jump
no that's a lot of threats that you've
just mentioned there
hang on a second does this mean that
where ye's position is collapsing
yes yeah i might yeah it seems like it
has kind of been that way for a couple
of moves it's all just turned um very
quickly i mean uh
i think this pushing the rook's pawn you
know i was trying to think where where
where did white go wrong i mean maybe
the position well it clearly wasn't as
good as i thought but pushing that pawn
only helped black so white wasted two
moves to give black the attack
because that night jump just just got to
this situation so i think this was the
the keep the key problem i think black
wanted to play that night jump anyway as
you mentioned and yeah it's the type of
position where you can't lose time you
can't lose moves okay white's knight has
retreated this gives black so many
tempting options first you look at uh
similar ideas to your anchors you bring
the knight forward
now the queen is indeed hit there's no
sacrifices there's a pin on this line as
well where does the queen even go
she can step back i mean you don't even
have to move the knight now it's so
tempting to jump in with the black queen
it's just collapsed it's all gone wrong
and suddenly the black queen can jump in
hitting the rook hitting the pawn next
to
her i mean it's uh it's just disaster
really i mean very least you can also
put your bishop on a square like this
one hit the rook in the corner lots of
options
and i mean
how can you resist not putting the
knight on that square i mean
you know it is such a nice move to play
you open the rook you move your knight
in you line up against your opponent's
king it's it's a move that
i i think he'll play but we did say that
about another night moving around didn't
play in the last game he could have
moved his knight to the edge of the
board in the last game and got an
overwhelming position and he didn't play
it
so uh will he find the right if it is
the right nightmare grieving to be
played right oh definitely i just have
to play it just because it looks nice as
well you can make an argument for the
queen coming in for the black bishop
coming to attack the rook
there are other tempting moves you could
just say okay i'm just not going to
worry just bring the other rook into the
game
they look all good as well i think the
queen oh this one is just too tempting
definitely the queen coming in as well
also
looks mighty fine
yeah
hitting the rook
yeah i don't even see how white reacts
to this if the white rook moves then
this pawn drops if the queen comes back
to offer a trade
because you only need to draw as black
you could just trade off the queens and
then win this pawn next move
pawn up you've gone for it yeah two
tempting yeah i had two tempting indeed
you know yeah big attack against the
white queen now the queen has to move
i it should be noted though aronian
again you can see he's scratching his
head and we say he doesn't get nervous
he's he's nervous a bit today his knee i
mean it's clear that he's uh he's
jiggling about a bit and
he knows again he's on the verge of
winning um this this match and he only
needs to draw in this game yeah
he needs his draw and he did talk a
couple of days even a couple of days ago
even before the finals he talked about
the hunger the appetite
it's clear
i mean not just the appetite for those
seeds and berries that we've been seeing
him eat it's just that appetite to beat
these young players and show the world
at 39 years old
actually by a distance the oldest play
in this whole tournament that
experience counts absolutely he's been
so impressive levon aronian and his form
has really been growing throughout the
tournament it started not so good
but here he is
maybe about to win the whole thing
never give up he started with two losses
in the whole tournament two losses in a
row wow and he's bounced back ah and i
remember his day two in the prelims
wasn't that impressive either
and uh it's quite curious actually this
is the first time i think we've ever
seen a final where we had someone who
finished seventh and eighth that's true
prelims
competing in the final we don't get
there
ever
no
yeah
very strange tournament in a way yeah
where all the young players shone so
early and then they kind of they shone
brightly but
the kind of stars faded and then the
older guy like levon aronian
he's been shining consistently
throughout but a bit brighter every day
yeah
that's true
meanwhile yeah so many tempting moves
again for black black's queen can come
in
again if you want to play it safe you
can eliminate the white bishop with the
black knight you could give a check with
the black knight in a different way
you can bring the black bishop to attack
the white rook
you're naming a fair few again there
for choice again that's the problem yeah
that's why levon's spending a fair bit
of time too many yeah i think this kind
of goes back to what i'm saying if you
if you were in black situation here um
looking at what your critical moves been
he's played the queen in you look at the
most critical move the move that creates
the biggest threat first and calculate
if that works if it works you don't even
need to look at other options and this
is the most critical move you attack the
rook you're threatening to win a piece
uh you're getting your queen into the
danger zone and um well i mean i i'm not
sure
okay well okay just don't take the rook
now don't take the rook now where's the
trap there is a trap yeah yep and uh
white's queen was actually threatening
to go up and capture the b7 pawn the
pawn in front of the black king and that
would have been checkmate but uh levon
has just defended that pawn now just
trading off the bishops so i suppose the
key line is here what happens if the
pawn pushes on can you um
can you can you just give up your rook
or something i expect minimum maybe
there's other options but if the pawn
steps forward again don't take it
because of checkmate
uh but yeah as you mentioned simon there
are other options you don't take the
pawn of course but
i guess at least you could just take
this one because you are threatening
checkmate yourself yeah and this is
probably why you spent a bit of time
just making sure because you are
material down i think i can't really
count anymore there's too many pieces
maybe you're not even
no you're not so i sort of lost count of
this uh this game so if you're not
material down then wow it's tremendous
yeah the queen is coming in this is
going to be disaster for white so
he needs something magical now
i guess he needs to trade the bishops
just process of elimination the bishop
is attacked the rook is attacked
you need to trade the bishops off and
then
now what
i mean the rook is just so loose right
now attacked by the black queen this is
still a pin
maybe you can defend everything on this
rank but it's not going to last for long
black can grab this ball and black's
rook can come and grab this pawn
it's one-sided traffic
in fact uh the position we have up there
on the board
that is white's best chance of defending
and it looks pretty miserable yeah yeah
yeah
if that's the best he's got then you
know it it's it's it's ugly playing like
that as well you don't want to go into
that kind of thing
yeah and it's i mean first of all you
just have to trade the bishops i think
he'll get there eventually but he's
looking for the move next move after
that and
because white's rook is so loose in the
middle of the board that's the only
reason i can suggest bringing the other
rook up
to defend it but
he's only got one minute now where ye
and that's as we've seen that's where
his mistakes have all been in the final
under the one-minute mark
it's really turned around
unfortunately for wei yi not only is he
suffering on the position he's suffering
in terms
of his clock and this just unfortunately
no
proper remedy either for his troubles
and uh there we see lavones
has he resigned he has resigned wow no
hope for wei the tournament
finishes levon aronian is the winner of
the ftx road to miami
no smile on his face so far he will
probably want to look over this game but
uh david how impressed are you with the
level neronian
extremely impressed especially today he
had a great day yesterday levon